[Música]
avanza la cob 26 y hoy es el turno de
los jóvenes cientos de activistas del
movimiento friday's por kutcher
liderados por la activista grata
schönberg protestaron por las calles de
glasgow las sesiones de hoy en la cumbre
se centran en cómo aprovechar la
conciencia ecológica de una juventud que
mira con recelo esta cita climática
tendremos reporte de nuestra enviada
especial desde glasgow
los obispos franceses reconocieron la
responsabilidad de la institución en los
miles de casos de abusos sexuales
cometidos en el seno de la iglesia una
comisión independiente contabilizó más
de 300.000 víctimas de casos de
agresiones sexuales perpetradas por
religiosos desde 1950
y en etiopía a las fuerzas que se oponen
al gobierno de abiyán me dicen que
desmantelaran el administrativo mientras
tanto el ejército le pide a los
militares retirados que se reincorporen
para combatir a los rebeldes de tigre
que se acercan cada vez más a la capital
bienvenidos a france 24 y a esta nueva
emisión de noticias yo soy manejar la
calle y es un gusto de estar con ustedes
comenzamos en escocia en el marco de la
cumbre climática con 26 este viernes los
jóvenes del movimiento de protesta fried
es propio sur se tomaron las calles de
glasgow con la activista sueca greta fom
bernie liderando las manifestaciones los
jóvenes le exigen acciones reales a los
líderes mundiales para combatir la
emergencia climática las protestas
coinciden con las sesiones de hoy de la
cob 26 que se centran en cómo aprovechar
la conciencia ecológica de las nuevas
generaciones para resolver la crisis
climática previamente nuestra enviada
especial en glasgow marina colorado
junto al coordinador del norte centro y
sudamérica para la coidh 16 nos contaban
que tanto peso tienen los jóvenes
hoy el presidente de la competencia y
salou sharma dijo que se deberían
considerar sus peticiones y las
prioridades de los jóvenes en las
negociaciones de esta cop 26 también se
anunció durante las negociaciones de
alto nivel que 23 países incluirán la
educación climática como parte central
de su programa educativo pero hoy se
entregó la declaración de la juventud
global un documento que salió de la
coidh 16 la conferencia de la juventud
que se celebró justo antes de que
empezara está con 26 y para conocer más
detalles me acompaña ernesto ojeda
coordinador de norte centro y sudamérica
para la coi 16 el resto muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros en france
24 te pregunto cuáles son las demandas
más importantes que hay en este
documento primero que nada marina
muchísimas gracias a france 24 por esta
invitación continuando con las demandas
me gustaría primero indicarles que esta
es la primera vez que se hace el
esfuerzo global de la juventud con más
de 40 mil firmas que se han obtenido a
través de todos los países del mundo
meramente consultando a
ministerios a organizaciones a
universidades y generalmente un llamado
a los jóvenes para que se unan en esta
declaratoria histórica de las demandas
primero que nada a los gobiernos y a los
políticos que tienen que planean
postularse les exigimos que se tomen
esto con seriedad tienen que involucrar
a los científicos y la perspectiva del
panel intergubernamental primero antes
de diseñar las políticas y después
tienen que asegurarse de que sean
efectivas e inclusivas y también se les
va a hacer responsables a largo plazo de
las decisiones que hayan tomado entonces
moviéndonos con el aspecto de
inclusividad tengo que celebrar que esta
es una de las cosas que más
representación latinoamericana ha tenido
y eso verdaderamente es algo de lo que
como mexicano estoy muy orgulloso así
que mientras estos son grandísimas
noticias todavía no se encuentran estas
personas en las mesas de decisiones en
donde primero tienen que ser consultados
ellos dado que son las zonas más
vulnerables los que primero sufren el
impacto del cambio climático ya los que
último se les pregunta de normal esto
incluye a grupos indígenas personas de
color de las personas con discapacidad
etcétera etcétera y pues moviéndome para
no quitar más tiempo hacia mi campo de
expertise que sería en ciudad de
ciudades sostenibles e involucra
tanto las acciones financieras que se
deben de tomar para la economía circular
el transporte y la movilidad sostenible
dentro de todas las ciudades la
infraestructura energética que debe ser
modernizada sobre todo de dónde
provienen estas energías y qué se hace
con los desechos que generan y pues con
eso me gustaría cerrar o si no no
terminó y brevemente 20 segundos tú
querías hacer un llamado a la unión del
activismo juvenil 20 segundos por
supuesto a todos los jóvenes que están
viendo esto este su llamado a la acción
necesitan unirse a la yunga mailing list
yo no es la constituyen cya oficial del
joven e triple de ene efe triple c para
los jóvenes es decir que todo lo que
ocurra de los jóvenes para los jóvenes a
través de jung o es que se hace llegar
al 1 efe triple c únase ahora y el
siguiente año nos vamos en la con 17 y
en noticias de europa los obispos
franceses reconocieron la
responsabilidad institucional de la
iglesia en los casos de pedofilia el
reconocimiento ciudadano después del
informe sobe que reconoció más de 210
mil víctimas por parte de tres mil
religiosos desde 1950 una cifra que
superaría 300.000 si se cuentan los
casos que implican también a laicos
vinculados con la institución desde
parís nuestra corresponsal natalia ruiz
previamente nos daba todos los detalles
al respecto
sí muy buenas tardes pues fue el
presidente de la conferencia episcopal
las de francia monseñor enrique mulambo
fue quien hizo estas declaraciones
diciendo que efectivamente los obispos
del país determinaban que si había una
responsabilidad de la iglesia como
institución en todos estos casos de
pedofilia aceptaban además que había
digamos una dimensión sistémica de estos
crímenes en el seno de la iglesia y
también explicó el que consideraba que
había un cierto número de un contexto
general una cierta mentalidad en el seno
de esta institución que había permitido
que se diera en este tipo de vejámenes
por parte de sus religiosos hacia los
menores de edad en estos momentos en
lourdes pues toda esta semana están
reunidos los 120 obispos del país en
esta reunión que realizan cada año y
pues están sobre todo centrándose en
este informe de las comisiones sube este
informe que fue entregado en octubre que
estuvo investigando durante varios años
los abusos sexuales en el seno de la
iglesia católica francesa en los últimos
70 años
y pues según este informe nos 216 mil
personas fueron víctimas de abusos
sexuales cuando eran menores de edad una
cifra que llega incluso a ser hasta más
de 300.000 si se tiene en cuenta
personas vinculadas a la iglesia pero
sin ningún cargo dentro del clérigo
además de esto pues monseñor emulando
fuego también dijo que en vista a esto
la iglesia pues también tenía un deber
de justicia y de reparación hacia las
víctimas víctimas que de hecho fueron
invitadas a esta reunión en lourdes pero
la mayoría de ellas declinaron la
invitación porque querían que toda esta
semana de conferencia pues estuviera
centrada únicamente sobre este informe
sobre la pedofilia en todo caso esta
reunión episcopal se termina el día
lunes en la ciudad de lourdes allí habrá
el discurso de clausura del presidente
de la conferencia episcopal seguramente
estaremos muy atentos de lo que él pueda
decir ahí para saber finalmente que más
decisiones han tomado los 120 prelados
reunidos allí y la unión europea- y
reino unido- entran en una nueva fase de
discusiones tras los acuerdos del break
shit el bloque de los 27 propuso
simplificar el comercio que pasa por
irlanda del norte y renovar el protoco
pero el gobierno británico rechazó la
idea y sigue amenazando con activar la
cláusula del artículo 16 que permite a
cualquiera de las partes tomar medidas
unilaterales si consideran que su
acuerdo posterior al break sit afecta
los intereses comerciales reino unido-
alega que los controles fronterizos
entre su provincia irlandesa y el resto
del reino unido- ponen en peligro los
acuerdos de paz de 1998 el bloque
europeo insiste por su parte en la
necesidad de los controles para proteger
el mercado único
uy
esperamos hacer algún proceso pero
honestamente la brecha entre nosotros
sigue siendo significativa pero veamos a
dónde podemos llegar aplicar a hoy el
artículo 16 por frost lo vamos a aplicar
el artículo 16 el día de hoy pero el
artículo 16 se mantiene sobre la mesa y
lo ha estado desde julio
escuchamos mucho el artículo 16 en el
momento que no quepa duda que aplicar el
artículo 16 para buscar la renegociación
del protocolo tendría serias
consecuencias serias para el grande del
norte ya que llevaría a inestabilidad la
imprescindibilidad y serias para las
relaciones entre la unión europea y el
reino unido- pues significaría un
rechazo de nuestros esfuerzos para
encontrar una solución consensuada para
la implementación del protocolo hablemos
ahora del cobi 19 por segundo día
consecutivo alemania registró un nuevo
récord de casos diarios las autoridades
sanitarias confirmaron hoy más de 37 mil
nuevos contagios y ayer se reportaron
más de 34 mil ambas son las cifras más
altas de toda la pandemia en el país
ante la situación el ministerio de salud
alemán acuerdo con las autoridades
en el futuro se debería aplicar una
dosis de refuerzo que sería seis meses
después de recibir la segunda vacuna
pero todavía no confirman cuándo
comienza a regir esta medida con
cualquiera que niegue el coronavirus y
diga que este virus no es tan malo
y cualquiera que dude y piense si debe
vacunarse o no cualquiera que piense que
es joven es sano e invulnerable tal vez
debería hablar con el personal de
cuidados intensivos demerit sin skating
la píldora contra el kobe y 19 de la
farmacéutica pfiezer es un 89% efectiva
para evitar casos de hospitalización y
de muerte así lo afirmó la compañía que
solicitará la autorización para su uso a
las entidades regulatorias de estados
unidos los resultados del estudio en los
que participaron
775 adultos mostraron una reducción del
riesgo en comparación con quienes
tomaron el placebo no se registró
ninguna muerte entre los participantes
de este estudio clip
en chile continúa la atención en el sur
del país después de la muerte de un
indígena mapuche por un impacto de bala
en enfrentamientos con fuerzas de
seguridad chilenas el miércoles los
mapuches dicen que el ejército comenzó
el ataque y las autoridades chilenas
afirman que la fuerza pública fue
atacada con armas de fuego mientras
patrullaba la zona el presidente
sebastián piñera pidió extender el
estado de emergencia en cuatro
provincias de las regiones de araucanía
y biobío mientras que ba puches
aseguraron que el ataque fue iniciado
por el ejército el informe desde luís
muñoz
con un grito contra la militarización
marcharon los 17 miembros indígenas de
la convención constitucional chilena
mientras las tensiones crecen en el sur
del país entre el estado y los mapuches
donde manifestamos nuestro rechazo al
acto de militarización con las trágicas
consecuencias que está teniendo en este
minuto en goal mapa y por otra parte
exigir una clara
el miércoles en zona mapuche en confusos
hechos entre uniformados y locales murió
un indígena hubo tres heridos y dos
detenidos el gobierno acusa a un ataque
armado mientras testigos aseguran que
los militares dispararon contra
vehículos que ocupaban la vía ante estos
sucesos el presidente sebastián piñera
pidió extender el estado de emergencia
en cuatro provincias de las regiones de
araucanía y bío bío éste fue declarado
el 12 de octubre y ya fue extendido en
una ocasión chile entero fue víctima de
un ataque de un grupo terrorista en la
provincia de arauco
con total
o sabía
amenazan a nuestra sociedad
estas regiones han vivido durante
décadas un conflicto histórico los
indígenas demandan tierras que
consideran propias por derecho ancestral
y que ahora pertenecen a grandes
empresas y hacendados la falta de
solución al conflicto ha generado una
escalada en la última década conflictos
históricos que contrastan con una nueva
constitución que prepara chile cuya
convención está presidida por una
mapuche elisa loncón
terminamos en áfrica porque en etiopía
una alianza de nueve facciones que se
oponen al gobierno afirmó que planea
desmantelar al ejecutivo del primer
ministro abhisit med ya sea con
negociaciones o a la fuerza por su parte
del ejército etíope le pidió a los
militares retirados que se reincorporen
para combatir a las fuerzas rebeldes de
tigre que ya están a unos 300 kilómetros
de la capital
es una ceremonia perfectamente
organizada delante de miles de
seguidores reunidos en un estadio de
addis abeba la alcaldesa de la capital
pasa revista a los nuevos reclutas
militares en unos días estos hombres
irán al frente para intentar frenar el
avance de los rebeldes hacia la ciudad
ya la vez
organicémonos todos estemos todos
preparados ciudadanos policías y fuerzas
armadas trabajan día y noche olvidemos
al cansancio no tenemos derecho a estar
cansados en este momento crítico
[Música]
es una ciudad en pie de guerra
el avance relámpago de los rebeldes tomó
por sorpresa al gobierno tras haber
controlado el tigre el mes de julio
acaban de hacerse con dos ciudades
estratégicas en la región de amhara el
miércoles se encontraban a 300
kilómetros de la capital donde se les
unieron combatientes del ejército de
liberación oromo otra facción rebelde
ahora el gobierno llama a sus
partidarios a frenar el avance de los
que califican como terroristas y etiopia
no se derrumbará etiopía prosperará
etiopía existirá para siempre
el parlamento ha declarado el estado de
emergencia en todo el país desde hace un
año el conflicto entre el gobierno y los
rebeldes ha dado un giro espectacular
con la retirada forzada del ejército
etíope
a raíz de este conflicto la suerte de
los civiles de la región preocupa mucho
a la comunidad internacional según la
onu más de 400.000 personas están al
borde de la hambruna con esto terminamos
nuestra emisión pero esperen más
información en minutos en france 24
[Música]